there are numerous whole areas, new reports
that box news has been dropped into a state
of complete chaos or more accurately Bedlam
according to the reports that are now out
as a result of the impeachment inquiry against
president Donald Trump.
Remember, I've been telling you for a long
time now, there is nothing fixed or immutable
about Trump and Fox news being on the same
team or on the same page.
Fox news is right wing media.
Fox news can be Donald Trump's vehicle for
promoting and defending his lies and his propaganda.
But also Fox news could separate from Trump
and say, we are for conservatism and conservative
values, which I find despicable, but certainly
Donald Trump doesn't represent.
Trump rep represents [inaudible] cartoonish,
ignorant Republican cluelessness not conservatism,
that's for sure.
Now, you might remember that this was the
case for awhile.
Early in the 2016 Republican primary, before
Donald Trump gained momentum in 2015 even
Fox news was not on Donald Trump's side.
And very publicly, they sparred.
But eventually Fox news came around and recently
the commentary people on Fox news, people
like Sean Hannity, Laura Ingram, Tucker Carlson,
that kooky judge Jeanine Pirro, they've remained
stalwart defenders of Donald Trump.
But some of the news people have not Shep
Smith, uh, Chris Wallace, John Roberts.
There are others who have just been telling
basic uncontroversial truths about Trump and
on Fox news that goes against what you're
seeing from the opinion people.
There are now endlessly entertaining reports
and New York magazine and in the guardian
and in other publications about the state
of total chaos in which Fox news now finds
itself.
Since the news of the impeachment inquiry
against Donald Trump went live.
To to understand this, you have to understand
that Fox news is one entity but it's huge
and it's a bunch of smaller entities.
You've got the news and opinion sides and
on Fox news those two sides are actually deliberately
blurred, but they are still ostensibly separate
sides.
You have each show being its own little Island
with its own production team and writers and
friends that they have in positions of power
Hannity for example, having Trump specifically
as one of his powerful friends and there are
massive fractures starting to develop at Fox
news since the Ukraine fiasco started.
So some examples of this.
Last week I played a clip for you where Shepard
Smith invited Fox news, a chief legal analyst,
senior legal analyst, judge Andrew Nepal Platano
on his show and Nepal.
Platano said, listen, this is not a political
analysis.
This is how these laws, these statutes are
defined.
And if you apply Donald Trump's actions to
the statutes, or maybe better said you apply
the statutes to Donald Trump's actions, Trump
committed crimes, and he is impeachable period.
Meanwhile, you have Tucker Carlson and Sean
Hannity chalking up the entire impeachment
inquiry to a witch hunt.
Tucker even invited this lunatic former prosecutor,
Joe diGenova on his show who straight up said,
Oh, that other legal analyst on, on Shep's
shown Andrew Nepal Tato he's a fool.
And you've got Fox news, legal analysts eating
themselves.
You have Fox news hosts and anchors going
after each other.
And the next day, Shepard Smith went right
back on air.
And he said that Tucker Carlson is a repugnant
for not backing the legal position of Andrew
in the Politan.
No, uh, when he was attacked on air.
And this then led to the Fox news CEO, Suzanne
Scott and the president of the channel J Wallace
having to interfere to cool it down.
And reportedly they told Shepard Smith according
to vanity fair, that if he attacks Tucker
Carlson on air again, he's going to be pulled
off the air all together.
That's not all.
You then saw Juan Williams on a Fox news show
called the five and he said that his Trump
loyalist colleagues are merely repeating Whitehouse
talking points while Sean Hannity was tweeting
that everyone is lying about what's going
on at Fox news, and this is exactly as predicted.
At a certain point, you're not defending so-called
conservative principles by defending Trump.
I am against these so-called conservative
principles, but Donald Trump doesn't actually
represent them in any serious way.
Nothing that is going on right now about defending
Trump's conservative view on abortion or taxation
or foreign policy is about conservatism.
This is just arguing about how corrupt, how
criminal, how treasonous is this administration
and actual conservative thinkers to the extent
that they exist, they're not seeing anything
that they can defend in Donald Trump other
than I guess he's undoing some of the things
that Barack Obama did.
There's a report that former Republican speaker
of the house, Paul Ryan, is pushing Fox news
to abandon Donald Trump.
Full stop.
Paul Ryan might have the power to do this
because he's now on the board of Fox news
since leaving the house of representatives
and another one of these revolving doors,
swamp filling instances, but next year is
going to be fascinating to watch on Fox news
from a media analysis point of view, but we
need to capitalize on this by punishing Trump,
by making sure that Trump is removed from
office because we don't want this entire Fox
news thing to be some mere curiosity or entertainment
only.
We want it to be productive in some way.
They are starting to eat themselves.
Democrats need to make sure not to do that
as I warned earlier in the show so that we
can actually take advantage of this situation
and get Donald Trump removed in November of